attention dans le coup les fameux bisou
à la française que célébrer carlos en
1978 mais aussi la poignée de main
l'étreinte et même le très désuet
bêtement autant de salutation difficile
en ces temps de qu'ovide où le contact
physique et des conseillers voire
interdit à commencer par la bise
le rituel de salutation à la française
on en raffole tellement qu'on s'en fait
une deux trois et même quatre en
fonction de sa région en normandie ces
deux dans la sarthe un peu plus basse et
de on vient du sud de la seine-et-marne
donc dans une ville qui s'appelle moret
sur loing et ont fait 4 biz fait deux
bises chez nous de bizet on a fait
beaucoup beaucoup oui mais pas forcément
avec tout le monde au début cantonné
dans le cercle familial
la bise se répand massivement france au
cours du 20e siècle aux relations
amicales
puis beaucoup plus récemment aux
collègues ce qui n'est pas sans poser de
problèmes
quelqu'un qui est nouvel embauché doit
très vite repéré les codes regarder un
petit peu ses collègues que font ses
collègues est ce qu'ils se serrent la
main
est-ce qu'ils s'embrassent si on n'est
pas assez intime pour se faire la bise
autant se serrer la main ce geste s'est
popularisé en europe au xixème siècle
d'abord dans le monde rural avant de
gagner le reste de la société
c'est un symbole fort d'égalité entre
deux personnes dans le monde de
l'entreprise serrer la main de ses
collègues est un rituel se serre la main
ou un jour si ce n'est pas plusieurs
fois parce qu'on se rappelle plus de la
première fois chez les plus jeunes
le tchèque remplace la poignée de main
autre nouveauté en provenance des pays
anglo saxons le ugg les trains en bon
français un geste très nourrissant selon
cette sociologue
c'est ce qu'apporte le câlin si vous
voulez le sentiment d'être aimée mais
aussi le sentiment d'appartenir à une
famille et plus largement à une
communauté humaine
tout le contraire du baisemain
réinventer à la fin du 19e siècle est
réservé à la crème de la crème
s'il est aujourd'hui tombé en désuétude
ce symbole de l'art de vivre à la
française pouvait même être appris à
l'école de la galanterie ne dit pas la
galanterie tout court parce que ça ne
veut rien dire je ne veux pas faire de
futurs casanova je veux dire la
galanterie française
ça n'a rien à voir avec la galanterie
tout court galanterie ou simple geste
amical
il faudra attendre la fin de l'épidémie
pour retrouver notre plaisir du contact
afin de se dire bonjour ou à revoir
données